STEVE: WELCOME BACK OVER THE
THANKSGIVING BREAK THIS BOOK
BY BOB WOODWARD TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WHEN IT CAME OUT
IN SEPTEMBER THOSE ON THE EAST
COAST SALIVATED OF TRUMP
WATCHING TV A LOT TALKING
ABOUT AN IGNORANT AND
DANGEROUS BARBARIAN.
.
>> IT IS A STUNNING LOOK
INSIDE THE TRUNK PRESIDENCY
EXPOSING A CHAOTIC WHITE HOUSE
BY A MAN WHO BELIEVES THE KEY
TO POWER IS FEAR.
>> WET WOODWARD HAS PRESENTED
IS A DEVASTATING PORTRAIT BOOK
WE HEARD ABOUT CHAOS AND
DYSFUNCTION BUT THE DETAILS I
LIKE NOTHING WE HAVE EVER
HEARD BEFORE.
>> ALL OF THOSE ANECDOTES RING
TRUE.
>> AND TO HOLD THAT UP AND TO
DELIVERY DISTORT WHAT IS IN
IT.
WHAT WOODWARD HAS DONE THAT
WOODWARD ACCOUNT IN FACT,
TELLS A STORY IF SOMEBODY
FOCUSES ON THE AGENDA AND
OBSESSED WITH DELIVERING
PROMISES HE WAS ELECTED ON
BLOCKED AT EVERY TURN AT
ALMOST EVERYONE AROUND HIM
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE REX
TO LISTEN DEFENSE SECRETARY
GENERAL MATUS THE WHITE HOUSE
STAFF SECRETARY THAT RESIGNED
IN DISGRACE THEY WERE IN THE
CIRCLE TO OVERTURN THE RESULTS
HIS SIGNATURE ISSUE FOR
DECADES HAS BEEN TRADE WITH
NAFTA AND OTHER TRADE DEALS HE
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN CLEARER.
.
>> WE WILL STOP THE TPP AND
TOTALLY RENEGOTIATE NAFTA ONE
OF THE WORST TRADE DEALS EVER
MADE BY MANKIND.
AND REJECT EVERY LAST - -
PROTECT EVERY LAST AMERICAN
JOB.
>> THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO
DELIVER BY RENEGOTIATING TRADE
DEALS THAT GARY :-COLON IN
GENERAL MATUS NOW HAS AT
CENTRAL THEME OF THE CAMPAIGN
WITH THE ENDLESS FOREIGN WARS.
.
>> I WILL NEVER SEND OUT THE
FINEST INTO BATTLE UNLESS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY AND WILL
ONLY DO SO IF WE HAVE A PLAN
FOR VICTORY WITH A
V-UPPERCASE-LETTER AND A TRY
EVERY TRICK IN THE BOOK TO
BREAK THE PROMISES TO CARRY ON
WITH THE FAILED POLICIES THAT
THE TRUMP 2016 AGENDA TWO AND
THAT ELITIST TO HAVE CHEAP
LABOR TO BIG BUSINESS
REPUBLICANS TO ESTABLISHMENT
DEMOCRATS COULD ANYONE HAVE
MISUNDERSTOOD?
.
>> AS FAR AS THE LAW IS
CONCERNED WE WILL BUILD THE
WALL IN CREATIVE ORDER AND
THEY WILL COME IN LEGALLY.
.
>> BUT ON THIS ISSUE WE
LEARNED THAT FAR FROM
UNDERMINING DEMOCRACY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS UPHOLDING
DEMOCRACY WITH THOSE POLICY
CHANGES THAT WERE VOTED FOR
THE WORD WORD BOOK PORTRAYS A
RESOLUTE PRESIDENT FIGHTING
EXACTLY THAT ELITIST ENEMY.
NOT JUST WITHIN HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION BUT HIS OWN
WHITE HOUSE BUT FAR TOO MANY
ARE STILL THERE NEXT WEEK WE
WILL BE THERE AND BE A SPECIAL
EDITION OF THE SWAMP IN THE